hello everyone and welcome to the last
classical game I played not ever but the
last classical game I've played so far
until I played the next tournament or or
the next match or something a lot of you
have been asking me to show some of the
games that earned me my candidate a
master title and a lot of you have been
asking me how come I don't compete in
litchi sidled arenas well my candidate
master title is a national one not an
international MA and not an
international one as most of the
tournaments that I play in Croatia are
not evil rated so my L always around I
don't know around 1900 but in my
national rating I have crossed 2,100 so
that's why I received the the National
candidate master title and there are no
games that actually allowed this I just
play the I know out of the last 20
classical games I've played that played
the you know some good chess and I was I
think I won 19 out of 20 I only lost one
so this is one of the games that I
decided to show you I don't really have
them anywhere digitally saved I opened
my drawer and this is the first one that
popped out it's from the last tournament
like I said I played and I already won
the tournament but I have to win this
game otherwise I don't I I don't think I
will be here I will have enough points
to get the candidate master title so
it's really an interesting matchup I'm
playing against uh well he's also from
my hometown from Krissie he's a very
successful young fellow he does well in
pretty much everything he does in school
he really you know kicks ass so to say
and he is pretty much a beginner in
chess but he really does well he's uh if
he invested more time in chests I really
think he would be an awesome player and
I don't think he's been he's played
chess for more than a year you know
seriously and he's not really serious
about it he just okay he attends some
classes but most of the work I think he
does by himself and one of the
interesting aspects is that I played him
last year where it was an interesting
game we played the same opening as this
year but I expected him to play the same
opening we played last year and I also
know that he watches my videos so also
was very interesting for me to see see
how I do so
I tried the exact thing I played last
year against him efore as I usually do
in classical in classical games he
played 'if I've Knight to f3 Knight to
c6 and I played for Bishop to c4 as I
usually do I don't really like the rule
opus and he played Knight to f6 as he
did last year and I continued with nice
so we have the two Knights defense and
Knight to g5 I'm going for the f7 square
and I wanted to see if he improved on
the game that we played last year so he
continues with the d5 as you should in
this position we have a capture son b5
and not Knight to a5 of course if you
capture then you can go into the fried
liver attack with Knight captures on f7
and if you don't know this line you
should know it as you will be able to
win a lot of cheap games in bullet
aganist beginners or even in blitz if
black captures and then after let's say
Queen to f3 check if he goes to G 8 then
you can just easily finish the game
immediately with a nice Bishop checkmate
so one way to go about it but of course
my opponent knows knows his opening C
goes nice day a5 the main line Bishop to
b5 check by me
c6 pushing the bishop back first I
capture and c6 with B captures and c6
and mount Bishop to e2 he kicks my
knight away h6 this is still the main
line I go back Knight to f3 and now he
plays efore last year and this is where
he improved he for is the strongest idea
here last year he played the Bishop to
d6 here and that is somewhat in an
inferior move but okay here he continues
in the strongest fashion we have E for a
Knights the e5 and now Bishop to d6 and
I play d4 still both of us just playing
main moves here and if I don't know when
I was studying some opening theory from
old books
I believe Queen to c7 was was the main
line here but here in the age of
computers it captures on d3 is the main
line and this is what my opponent played
who remember I said that he doesn't
really play all that much chess and he's
you know he's pretty much great at
everything he does so playing the main
line still after 10 moves with Knight
captures on d3 now I have to capture
with the night otherwise I'm gonna lose
a piece on e5 with a knife
first on d5 and now to give you an
example for example
Zhang Sheng Zheng had this position
again spent ala Hari Krishna in 2018 in
China where Hari Krishna castled here
but this is not the main line the main
line is going to c7 and this is what my
opponent plays what our game will
transpose into the heart Krishna game
once more I play h3 as I want to castle
I don't want eh to pawn to remain a
target material castles I Castle here
and here we have rook to e8 Hari Krishna
in that game against the zheng played c5
here where you wanna play Bishop to b7
and get your light square Bishop to
control this diagonal but here he went
rook to e8 and okay I thought I I have
to start developing my pieces I I am up
a pawn but if I don't start developing
my pieces you don't really get to enjoy
our extra point so I thought about maybe
Knight a three Knight f3 nights
sided to play Bishop to f3 just gaining
control of this nice diagonal and ok
it's not a problem the engine doesn't
mind this move with Bishop to e6 there
is one game in the database for Bishop
the f5 was played but here after Bishop
to e6 we have a completely new game as
of move 15 so very nicely done and here
again yeah you could try something like
Knight to c3 start developing in some
normal fashion but I didn't like this I
was expecting Ruby eight or something
and then I didn't want I didn't know
where to develop my dark square Bishop I
can't really develop it the f4 I can go
to g5 III what what's it really doing
there I'm gonna make my b2 upon a weak
pawn so instead I decided for Bush up to
d2 seems really weird but I wanted to
get my Bishop over to C 3 and okay he
played Knight to c4 a nice idea
excellent square for the knight he
attacks my Bishop pressure is the b2
pawn I play Bishop the c3 and now I do
have my bishops on very strong diagonals
but on the other hand when's the last
time you saw a bishop on c3 and an f3
those are usually squares reserved for
the Knights but if it works why not and
here he goes Knight to e4 he says I
either want to capture your c3 bishop he
wants to eliminate my bishop pair or he
wants me to capture with the lights
worker so here I decided that my dark
square bishop is the better
here and I capture on e4 Bishop captures
with rook captures and this allows me to
develop without wasting time as now I
can develop my knight with an attack
against the knight and the rook so I
play Knight to D to attack both of his
pieces and now he trades Knight captures
I get to develop my queen queen capture
son d2 and now he plays rook a to e8 so
now he has two excellent bishops here
and he has control of the e-file he has
nicely double rooks on the e-file it
would be somewhat better you know if
this bishop was here would be a much
nicer battery but you know you can't
always get everything but I don't mind I
don't mind the bishop pair in the
control and the e-file I just play troop
fe1 and I say okay I'm pretty happy with
trading rooks for example if he traded
here let's say I trade he trades I get
Queen captures and I'm still up upon so
I don't really mind him plays c5 get his
Bishop to this very nice diagonal but I
think I can defend and then start
playing around his Queen side weaknesses
and I can always block one of his
bishops for example I have triple
control over d5 square I can play Bishop
to e5 trade off one of the bishops and
then he doesn't really have the
advantage of the bishop pair I'm just up
a pawn and if he wants the prevent is by
playing something like f6 then that's a
weakening of the Kings side I have Queen
e6 check and then my position seems
seems perfectly nice I have an extra
pawn and all is well so here he has to
decide what to do here probably best
here is to play C 5 get his Bishop to
this diagonal if I want to force me to
capture on e4 but you know not not force
matters but here he played Bishop to f4
and it's a very nice idea that I checked
before I played rook F to e 1 but I
didn't like it and I didn't like it for
a good reason so feel free to pause the
video here and try to figure out why I
didn't like this
Bishop to f4 idea that my opponent
played while I give you a couple of
seconds for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations you are an
excellent offer of Queens and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
the the engine gives Queen captures on
f4 is best here this is not what I
played he offers the Queen here because
the point is if you capture the Queen
now then rook captures with check King
to age
knife captures here and you get this
position after Queen captures rook 81
where you have two rooks for a queen and
the bishops are of opposite colors the
white is better here but I didn't like
it this position probably because I
don't know it's been a long time but
probably since the bishops are of
opposite colors I thought maybe c5 there
should be seven he can you know start
some trouble on my King's side so
instead I did offer the Queen but not in
this fashion I didn't play Queen
captures on i-4 instead I played rook
captures on e4 and now my idea is now he
can't capture the Queen because now if
he captures I just capture on e8 king h7
check and now just pick up the bishop
and now I have two rooks in the night
for for a queen which is of course
completely winning now so here I'm
saying you cannot capture my queen you
have to just capture the rope he played
the rook captures on e4 and now I just
played Knight captures an f4 I say I'm
trading down and you have you know three
points I've only two I'm up upon I'm I
don't have a problem playing this
endgame I will pull this for a win and
here he should probably capture with the
Queen and after trading Queens we get
this endgame where I get rude rogue d1
the bishops are of opposite colors but
still like I said I did enjoy my I did
like my two points against three points
and I don't know I I thought it was
gonna be too hard to defend the Queen
side weaknesses but here he actually
played rook captures on f4 and now this
really doesn't work so once again feel
free to pause the video here try to find
what move I played it's really not all
that difficult not even a tactic I'm
sure we all see it
rook a rook to e1 and now there are
simply too many threats for for black to
deal with there's Bishop to e5 just you
know winning material and it's very hard
to prevent this there is no way to
prevent it rook to e8 also a pretty big
threat so whatever you play here doesn't
really work if you play f6 trying to
prevent this Bishop T if I move still
get rook e8 check engage seven and now
Queen to III would be deadly with the
idea of rook to e7
now that the King side is weakened and
there's again not that much you can do
after rookie seven lands the Queen will
have less
where's to keep an eye on this rook here
so whatever you play let's say Bishop c4
rook d7 is a big threat let's say Queen
b6 you have to keep an eye on the rook
here but now Queen captures and there is
no way to defend the g7 pawn so this is
you you can give one check but there are
no more no more useful checks you will
you can try threaten some nasty
discoveries here but you know black is
in the in the mating web so for example
a checkmate would follow so here there
are no good moves for black and my
opponent unfortunately blundered here he
played he he just wanted to get out of
the pin and he played Queen to c8 and he
hung a whole rope here so not not the
most classiest way to win my my cm title
but you know like I said it's not this
game that won the same title it's the 20
previous ones that I was able to play
with chess in this is just the one that
I absolutely had to win and even though
it was against a low-rated opponent you
can see that my opponent really studied
his theory and he he played the people
in a nice game even though when you play
this line when you sacrifice a pawn for
activity you generally want to avoid
trading and here my opponent just
allowed me to trade material and then
just take advantage of the position and
well of course in the end he blundered
but it was still a very nice game from
him and I really enjoyed it and he
really well played much better than last
year so I can only imagine if he
continues brushing up his chest kills ha
how strong he will be next year so this
is one of the games you wanted to see
one of the games I will show some other
games if you're if you're interested
still since we have two days now of rest
in the Riga feeder Grand Prix so I
thought it was a nice time to show one
of the games so congratulations to
Mattel for for playing such a very nice
game I was able to win the tournament
with 100% and I was very happy about it
and win my cm title but yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it and I
would just like to make a short
announcement I hit 20,000 followers on
Instagram and I will be making a chess
quiz nice 15 questions you know to check
out your vast knowledge I was gonna do
it and YouTube maybe but I don't know
my air conditioning is going to be
repaired and I don't know if I will be
able to use the PC then so I can't
really make a promise that's why I'm
gonna use my smartphone to do an
Instagram as I can do it pretty much
anywhere so it will be held at 8:00 p.m.
tonight all your pian summer time so
some two and a half hours well two hours
after you see this video if you see it
right away already hopefully I didn't
announce it pretty much everywhere but
for those who haven't seen it hopefully
you can make it as it's it's gonna be
very nice it's gonna be easy 15
questions if you're a follower on the
channel so III don't think you should
worry about anything I would like to
thank Jeff grace and David legal for a
contributor to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos here
think all for watching and I will see
you soon hopefully with some more
interesting content thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day and happy
International chest day to everyone